high-rise buildings dominate Frankfurt
skyline more than any other German city
the financial district is a tourist
attraction and the locals have also
learned to love their skyscrapers now
Frankfurt has another building in the
east of the city removed from the center
the new ECB headquarters does its order
it's like the icing on the cake it's a
bit great compared to the others over
there but ok they're bankers they sit
inside and don't see it from the outside
I think it fits really well but I think
it's a shame that it's so far out of the
city of ours and this employees actually
began moving into the building last
November designed by Austrian architect
Vulpix
it consists of two high towers linked by
a glass atrium the goal was to have a
building that stands out from the crowd
our instructions were that the ECB
needed a landmark building we were also
told that it needed to create a visual
link between the existing city centre
and what will probably be the new city
centre the German architecture Museum in
Frankfurt is running an exhibition
looking at how the city skyline
developed it goes back to the 1960s when
Germany's major banks started building
their headquarters in the city the
exhibition also explores future trends
it's a mere huts issue the ECB
hasn't joined the skyscrapers of other
banks but it's created a new nucleus
further away which will probably soon
grow and get neighbors knocked bun
becomes it at a cost of 1.3 billion
euros the ECB headquarters was never
intended to just blend in it was
designed to stand out from the other
financial organizations the design
emanates power and prestige critics see
it as the wrong message during this time
of austerity the building has become
almost as hotly debated as eurozone
policy itself I could do it architecture
is political architecture is very
weighty and as everyone knows weight
costs money and where there's money
there's politics so whether you like it
or not every building becomes a
political statement I'm a fan of Europe
and I was commissioned to design a
building for Europe to intervene the
nerve center of the new ECB building is
the meeting room on the 41st floor with
a panoramic view of the city
the architect says he never lost sight
of the residents of Frankfurt while
designing the building
is this north wind it in hi it's
important today more than ever when you
have anonymous designs and anonymous
structures to create landmarks for a
city that people can identify with they
help create a sense of home to Anam hey
map key food bags
the other glided I saw something between
absurd kids because it's a bit out of
the way
not like these buildings it's pretty
noticeable when you're sitting in a
plane you see it coming up on the right
and think oh I'm back home in Frankfurt
over the people of Frankfurt it's a big
piece of home that's really the way it
is when I come in on the train and see
it from far away I think now I'm back
home it's finished it's a house it's not
the tallest building in Frankfort
but it can be seen from far and wide not
just as a new structure in Frankfurt but
also as a symbol for Europe
Oh